nine and a half weeks until brexit day
in the government secret plans reveal
remarkable changes on what it refers to
as day one
No Deal deletes border force documents
obtained by Sky News not shown to MPs or
the public until now reveals the
assumptions government is making about
the impact and disruption for Freight
for travelers and for those combating
organized crime and illegal migration
the 20 page document on No Deal brexit
assumptions says leaving the EU without
a deal would lead to border confusion
and delay that may lead to an increase
in organised crime activity and an
additional clandestine threat some
frontline operational capability at the
border may be impacted by the loss of
access to EU systems and data
UK passengers may no longer be able to
use eg AIT's electronic passport gates
in Europe and be questioned about why
they're travelling so-called intentions
checking this expected to cause
disruptions of flight schedules and
significant queues a former police
border officer Chris Hobbs is already
deeply concerned about what happens at
the border in a few weeks time there
could be border force officers taking
away from other duties customs
particularly looking for drugs looking
for weapons they could be taken away an
hour at the moment to look at and to
deal with queues so if you're an
organized crime network in Europe you
will be looking at brexit and rubbing
your hands with anticipation in document
the border force technology is a no deal
loss of access to the EU databases the
UK relies on for electronic passports
criminal checks being replaced by vastly
inferior Interpol databases is Britain
ready I think it shows real concerns
about the implications for our border
security in the event of no deal this
suggests our border force and all of the
support services simply aren't ready to
deal with no deal but also that their
what the work they do would be
downgraded they would be using weaker
systems to try and identify criminals
crossing the border weaker systems to
try and identify dangerous weapons being
shipped across the border and so I think
it raises serious questions about our
security at our borders in the event of
no deal with
suggesting what they called and managed
No Deal remain unconvinced I think it is
very convenient for the government that
just by accident it happens to leak at
this time and I've been a member of
parliament for 18 years and these things
don't happen by accident today however
the boss of the civil service did
acknowledge some issues I've never shied
away from the fact that this is a
complicated problem and I've never
pretended that you know it's all going
to go swimmingly well in the event of a
No Deal which is just a few days away or
potentially the Home Office said it
wouldn't comment on leaked documents but
they do show officials already fearing
and anticipating scenes such as this
across the UK border on what they call D
1 nd they won No Deal
first of all Islam Sky News